ich würde mich nicht mehr sicher fühlen
auf diesem planeten
halo die maske ab und jetzt willkommen
beim neuen video und wir haben gerade
und scheiß halbzehn ich konnte mich noch
nie daran erinnern dass ich um halb zehn
schon mal ein video gemacht habe ich
meine halbzehn entweder ich schlafe oder
ist jetzt schon lange in der schule habe
ich hab ja einfach frei leute ihr wisst
bescheid letzten sonntag habe dieses
video von mir was jungs am handy
wirklich machen und da hab ich gesagt ja
kommen wenn ihr bock auf was mädchen am
ende weg machen
dann sagt es mir und wird aber schon so
die ein oder andere positive rückmeldung
und ihr habt auch wirklich wieder
fleißig kommentiert ich habe ein paar
kommentare rausgesucht allerdings kann
ich das also ein paar kommentar da
dachte ich was laura doch kein ich war
echt wirklich überrascht dass ihr das am
handy macht also ich lese dass gleich
ein bisschen vor ich kann das irgendwie
nicht so gut hat filme wie sonst immer
deswegen welches einfach kommentieren
mal wieder sonja ich stehe hier einfach
und lava wie früher haltbar und ja wenn
es euch gefällt dann gefällt so ach ja
was ich auch ganz oft wirklich heftig
oft in den kommentaren gelesen aber so
jung macht doch mal bitte auch
sonderausgabe davon so was verliebte
mädchen und jungen wirklich machen da
dachte ich so eigentlich willst du so
was nicht mache weil keine ahnung auf
dieses thema hat irgendwie nicht so weit
aber leute ich habe mir gedacht ja
kommen wenn dieses video 20.000
laischaft dann kommt am nächsten sonntag
die erste folge halt so was jungs oder
was verliebte jungs wirklich machen und
danach in sonntag was verliebte mädchen
weg machen also ja das hab ich dann
einfach raus deswegen dort oben in den
bottroper und jetzt geht's los mit den
kranken kommentare wo ich mir dachte ein
ernsterer also ein paar von euch mädchen
haben irgendwas kommentiert was ihr
wirklich am handy machen und das lese
ich euch jetzt mal vor und ihr könnt
wirklich immer was zu meckern gibt die
ich glaube es gibt viel zu meckern
schreibt das in die kommentare
und wenn nicht dann find ich echt
überrascht okay leute passt auf erste
aussage wenn ich am handy bin dann
stoppe ich manchmal mädchen die richtig
schön sind und suche fehler an ihrem
gesicht weil ich so neidisch bin und
mich nicht zu hässlich finden will ich
dachte wirklich erst soja dieser
kommentar rennen mit soja ich schaue
nach hübschen mädchen um vielleicht
inspiration zu finden oder so aber warum
machst du das denn man ich finde sowas
immer richtig schade ohne scheiß sagt
einfach mit euch selber zufrieden und es
ist auch wirklich das habe ich schon so
oft gesagt es gibt immer andere leute
die euch hübsch bin auch wenn ihr es das
ist bei mir auch so es gibt den einen
oder anderen tag war so zum beispiel
heute denke ich mir wieder vor allem
sieht so gut aus
morgen nicht
morgen denke ich mir dann vielleicht
wieder bei alex du scheiße aus so aber
es gibt trotzdem genug budgets die mich
gern finden
ich hoffe das hat meine mama es sich
gehört und das war jetzt auch nicht so
ernst gemeint doch angeschoben okay
leute next aussage mädchens sorgen wenn
sie am handy sind meistens ihren schwarm
und all seine ex freundin und deren
freunde und freundinnen und müssen am
ende alles über diese person wo sie
wohnen was sie für hobby haben wie viele
freunde die ex freundin schon hatte und
so weiter und sie vergleichen sich mit
der ex-freundin was also ganz ehrlich
irgendwo hört der spaß auf ich meine
wenn das jetzt wirklich jedes mädchen
machen würde dann ich würde mich nicht
mehr sicher fühlen auf diesen planeten
ja die mädchen jetzt macht ihr das ja
oder nein schreibt in die kommentare
wenn ihr es mag schreibt ja hoffentlich
nicht aber wenn ich dann schreib bitte
nein schreibt nein okay leute beim
nächsten kommentar dachte ich echt wo
sind wir jetzt hier gerade so was du
dich auf der seite verliert also wie
mädchens dort mal auf jungs mit six pack
leiten dann mit einem n ganz viele fotos
von der oben ohne art und schicken dann
die fotos an freundinnen ab von solchen
fotos ziemlich viele auf handy hofft ist
nicht nur bei mir so wäre etwas peinlich
ps wir feiern die fotos falls alles klar
obwohl bis auf den satzbau finde ich das
eigentlich gar nicht so schlimm ich
meine es gibt doch fast kein jungen der
auf seinem handy keine fotos von
irgendwelchen mädchen hat die ihr wisst
was ich meine
deswegen hab six pack fotos auf dem
handy schickt dir deine freundin ist mir
komplett egal ist ok hab ich kein
problem mit so auch wenn das vielleicht
nicht jedes mädchen macht glaube ich
schreib in die kommentare macht oder
nicht ich denke mal nein nicht lügen
nicht lügen also eigentlich kann es da
auch das kann ja ich weiß es nicht man
also warum sollten wir jungs dürfen aber
ihr mädchen nicht deswegen macht es
ruhig habe ich kein problem mit steht
wenigstens zu so und kommen wir zur
letzten aussage wir mädchen machen
videos sowie singen und tanzen zeigen
die aber kaum jemandem lava doch keine
hinzu was zieht man das steht ihr recht
alleine da
mist in more than just wenn ja darf
steht direkt total alleine da das ist
echte sache so weiter zu so was kann man
doch nicht bringen man ganz ehrlich was
mit dem video wie gesagt nächste woche
also wenn ihr bock ab 2011 sind denke
ich locker drin
wir sehen uns dann am nächsten montag
oder dienstag wieder keine ahnung es
kommt es wie gesagt schon habe ich schon
den letzten videos gesagt ganz viele
videos jede woche vier bis fünf videos
keine ahnung deswegen folgt mir aufs
netz oder instagram damit ihr nichts
verpasst waren diese videos anderen
kommen das war ein gewinn
die jungen linken mit meinem letzten
video steckt ist auf jeden fall ab da
ging es um so erkennt man eine
bordsteinschwalbe und ja wir sehen uns
da natürlich am nächsten montag oder
dienstag wieder ich wünsche einen
schönen sonntagabend durch